Speaker 1: So we spoke yesterday about the
sort of disturbing reality that at this late
stage in the game, you still see most prominent
Republicans quite fervently, feverishly and
feverishly behind Donald Trump. We at this
rally in Iowa over the weekend, Chuck Grassley
was there saying, Trump's great all this different
stuff. It's very, very concerning. And one
of the ways in which Republicans signal there,
at least for now, continued public loyalty
to Trump, whatever they believe privately,
they may hate the guy privately. Think he's
terrible for the Republican Party, whatever,
right? But the way you signal that at least
publicly you're still behind Trump is when
you're asked, Did Donald Trump have the election
stolen from him? You don't say no. You come
up with anything you can to avoid saying no.
And that's exactly what radical bomb throwing
Republican Congressman Steve Scalise did over
the weekend when he was interviewed by Chris
Wallace. Now it took me a couple of days to
get to this. We were off Monday for the federal
holiday and I didn't have time yesterday,
but I want to get to it today. It happened
on Sunday. Chris Wallace just keeps asking
Steve Scalise, was the election stolen from
Donald Trump or will you say that it was not
that that Joe Biden simply won? And Steve
Scalise goes through every single iteration
of how you don't say no. So let's just jump
into it. We'll go through these examples and
we'll talk about them, and it's interesting
to see how Chris Wallace handles it. But really,
for me, the more interesting part is to analyze
the language that Scalise uses to answer questions
that are the ones being asked in order to
avoid simply saying it wasn't stolen from
Donald Trump. Let's jump in U.S. capital.
Speaker 2: Let me ask you one last question
in this regard. Clearly, there were irregularities
in the last election. There are irregularities
in all elections. But I I want to ask you
a specific question do you think the twenty
twenty election was stolen from Donald Trump
Speaker 1: and to be I am not going to just
I'm not going to try not to jump in all the
time. The way I've been saying this is anecdotal
irregularities aside, which there would always
be in an election in a country of 330 million
people. Do we have any evidence that the irregularities
in even one state rose to the level of being
materially substantive as far as who the winner
was? That's that's the core
Speaker 2: and continued continuing to make
that charge. Not having states do election
reforms, but specifically making this charge
that the election was stolen. Do you think
that that hurts undermines American democracy?
Well, Chris, I've been very clear from the
beginning. If you look at a number of states,
they didn't follow their state passed laws
that govern the election for president. That
is what the United States Constitution says
now.
Speaker 1: That's that's that's absurd. Think
about even what Steve Scalise says their states
didn't follow their own rules, which is a
matter of the U.S. Constitution. No, it's
not. It's quite literally a matter of the
state rules. It's not a U.S. constitutional
issue. This is backwards and sideways and
nonsense. Now the other issue is if states
didn't follow their own rules, would that
be a reason to give that state to Trump? Is
that evidence that Trump actually won a state
in which the rules weren't followed? So first,
you have to prove that then you have to prove
it's materially substantive, then you have
to prove that it would have made the election
go a different way if there were people who
voted absentee and then moved and then didn't
call and say, I no longer live in the state.
That may be something that took place. It
may not. But then to say, and that means Trump
should have won the state is not backed by
the evidence.
Speaker 2: You don't say that the states determine
what the rules are. They say the state legislatures
determine that the states all services, they
didn't follow those state legislative districts
and certify those legislative rules. Right.
But at the end of the day, are we going to
follow what the Constitution says or not?
I hope we get back to what the Constitution
says.
Speaker 1: Remember, this is not about the
U.S., it's just it just is not about the U.S.
Constitution. He's talking about state rules,
state certification.
Speaker 2: But clearly in a number of states,
they didn't follow those legislatively. So
you think the election was stolen? But what
I said is there are states that didn't follow
their legislatively set rules. That's what
the United States Constitution says. And so
then I think there are a lot of people that
want us to get back to what the Constitution
says we should be doing, not just with elections,
with a lot of other things.
Speaker 1: This is where Trumpists end up
repeating. They ignored the Constitution in
the 2020 election because they hear people
like Steve Scalise say it without explaining
it. And they do.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I don't know. And then there
are some people that want to just ignore what
the Constitution says and do their own thing.
You know, that's been a debate that's been
going on in this country for a long time.
But just getting back to the Constitution,
I have that problem. And there certainly I
can
Speaker 1: understand that getting back to
the Constitution is different than did Trump
have the election stolen from him? And was
he the rightful winner? Two totally different
things out there.
Speaker 2: There was a rally for President
Trump yesterday, and a number of people said
Joe Biden is backed by President Donald Trump
is my president. I guess the question is,
do you think the election now last time? I
promise. Do you think the election was stolen
or not? I understand you think there were
irregularities and things that need to be
fixed. Do you think the election was stolen?
And it's not just a regulated states that
did not follow the laws, which the Constitution?
Speaker 1: I think he'll answer this time.
What do you think
Speaker 2: says they're supposed to follow
when you see states like Georgia cleaning
up some of the mess and people calling that
Jim Crow law? That's a flat out lie. I think
with absolutely no law against that sort of
thing. All right. Yeah. But but the law says,
again,
Speaker 1: guys, he's not going to answer
the question. He's not going to answer the
question. This is how you play coy and avoid
the wrath of Trump supporters and avoid the
wrath of Trump himself. I don't think there
is really any way that Steve Scalise believes
this crap in any literal sense. I don't think
Steve Scalise believes Donald Trump actually
won the election. I just don't think so. And
Adam Kinzinger and others have said almost
no Republicans believe that. Maybe a couple.
I think, you know, maybe Marjorie Taylor Greene,
I don't know. But there is just no way that
Steve Scalise believes that. But he doesn't
want the wrath of Trump supporters or Trump.
He's signaling his loyalty. They see this
as a war. As I've said before, where maybe
you've got a liar, maybe you've got a claim
to believe something you don't really believe
or whatever the case may be. This was three
four attempts by Chris Wallace to just get
a simple answer, and the whole point is not
answering is how you prove your loyalty. Not
answering is how you prove your loyalty. And
Steve Scalise is doing it. And we'll see how
long they keep doing it. It appears as though
it's going to be for quite
some time.